let's go next to
uh let's go to chris from massachusetts
chris you're on the air
hey david hello
so i don't know if i ever got a chance
to
congratulate you on the race against the
majority report to a million subscribers
oh my goodness you're saying from like a
over a year ago over a year ago oh well
thank you i appreciate the
congratulations
the strategies of stealing the set
panels very effective yeah because
people thought they were like okay wait
a second this is how it worked
i stole sam's panels right
so then people who were subscribed to
sam would come across my videos
they'd recognize the panels and go oh
yeah this is the this is the guy i'm
subscribed to they would see wait i'm
not subscribed i must have gotten
accidentally unsubscribed they would sub
and i would basically trick them into
subscribing to me with my panels it was
genius
brilliant yep but i wanted i called in
to warn you there is a new threat on the
horizon
in a man called brian tyler cohen uh oh
is he getting panels
no well i already noticed that
you already copied his frameworks
mic stand
oh no no
i have never even seen his doesn't he
use a lavalier i've never seen him use a
boom mic actually oh he uses a boom mic
well
all right okay well that will be decided
but the next strategy yep is we got to
get multiple cameras set up now oh yeah
and we got to go with a cleaner
background maybe dress you in a suit
instead of the zip up button up i used
to wear a suit i got off of it because
it felt pedantic
well okay brian tyler cohen he's he is
like predicted to hit 2 million
subscribers in like 2024 you're not
predicted to hit 2 million until 2027.
oh my god i'll be retired
together here let's work it out i'm open
to all ideas
okay all right good luck i gave you a
couple couple tips there i want to see
him implemented good strategy moving the
show to new york too
because uh i don't know if you knew this
but during the big live event the
majority report was putting on in boston
there was a a plot to steal back the
panels is that right you did a little 4d
chess move on them there wait sam did a
show in boston
yeah uh earlier this year oh wow
interesting i didn't know that or
actually was it i think they might have
done one in new york and rescheduled the
boston show oh okay but that was like
the main i think that was the main
reason they were coming to boston in the
first place to steal the panels when i
they thought when i was here back then
oh wow
yeah that's crazy well good thing i
moved out of there
of course all right chris thank you very
much appreciate the call there's chris
from massachusetts with a lot of very
very interesting ideas that we're we're
going to look into every single one of
them very strongly